hi
everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel today
we will be discussing docker in 5
minutes in this video we have our expert
math who will be executing the basic
commands
for docker on ubuntu so without further
ado
let's get started so we're gonna go
ahead and start a demo of how to use the
basic commands to run docker so to do
this
we're going to open up terminal window
or command line deploying whether you're
running linux pc or
mac and we're going to go ahead and the
first thing we want to do is
see what our docker image lists are so
we can go sudo docker images and this
will give us
well first we'll enter in our password
so let's go enter that in
and this one that gives us a list of our
docker images and
here are the doc images that have
already been created
in the system and we can actually go
ahead and actually see the processes
that are actually running so
i'm going to go ahead and open up this
window a little bit more but this will
show you the actual
processes and the containers that we
actually have and so
on the far left hand side you see under
names we have learn simply learn
be underscore cool these are all just
different ones that we've been
working on so let's go ahead and create
a docker image
so i'm gonna do sudo docker
run dash d
dash p 0.0.0.0
go on 80 colon 80.
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run
an albanto image and this will run the
latest image and
what we have here is a hash number and
this hash number
is a unique name that defines
the container that we've just created
and we can go ahead and we can check
to make sure that the container actually
is present so we're going to do
sudo docker.ps and this actually shows
some there so it's not
in a running state right now but that
doesn't mean that we don't have it
so let's list out all the containers
that are both running and in the exit
state so let's do sucker
ps dash a and this lists
all the containers that i have running
on my machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state
and in the exit stage and here we see
one that we just created about a minute
ago
and it's called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and there we go
so let's change that to that new dock
container to a running state so scroll
down
and we're going to type sudo
docker
run dash i t
dash dash name
my
so this is going to be the new container
name it's going to be my
docker so this is how we name our docker
environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
ubuntu
and dash bin dash bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're gonna go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker return
and that started that docker image and
let's go ahead and check against the
other running
docker images to make sure it's running
correctly so sudo docker
ps and there we are underneath name
on the right hand side you have to see
my docker along with the
other docker images that we created so
this is all about docker in five minutes
if you have any queries in the topics
covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our experts are 24 7 ready to
solve all your queries
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here